when the shield premiered on FX in 2002
the program pushed the limits of what
could be portrayed on cable programming
it's been well over a decade since the
series helped spark a small screen
revolution so let's look back at some
little-known facts about this
extraordinary show this is the untold
truth of the shield risky business
before 2002 the only original series on
FX was the Baywatch parody son of the
beach once the shield joined the lineup
the series broke new ground testing the
limits on violence nudity and language
it was very risky material open your
mouth baited the emmy-winning series
centered around corrupt cop Vic Mackey
masterfully played by Michael Chiklis
Mackey leads an experimental anti-gang
unit within the LAPD often using highly
unethical means to fight crime inspired
by the success of the shield the network
brought other edgy new shows into the
fold like nip/tuck damages and Rescue Me
Chiklis told TV week I think the face of
basic cable was changed forever it made
a lot of people think why can't we the
walking dead connection in 2007 Frank
Darabont the writer director of the
Shawshank Redemption took a break from
big-budget filmmaking to direct an
episode of the shield after filming the
season 6 episode chasing ghosts Darabont
wanted to further explore televisions
possibilities it wasn't long before he
started developing a zombie horror
series based on the comic book The
Walking Dead bringing The Walking Dead -
TV proved to be an uphill battle with
network execs but when AMC finally
greenlit the post-apocalyptic series
Darabont remembered his roots and
enlisted some of the shield's production
team including Charles eglee and Glen
Mazzara The Walking Dead's future
showrunner Michael Chiklis his
transformation before the shield Michael
Chiklis was known for playing much
cuddler characters like Tony Scali the
police officer in ABC's the Commish but
the actor was tired of being typecast
telling the archive of American
television that a conversation with his
wife Michelle Moran inspired him to make
a career change
she told him it's not incumbent upon the
studios and the network's to reinvent
you it's incumbent upon you to reinvent
yourself that reinvention of course
required Chiklis to also reinvent his
physique in order to land different
rolls according to Men's Journal Chiklis
relied on healthy portion controlled
meals and ran seven miles a day six days
a week to transform his appearance and I
just hit the gym three hours a day and I
got in sick shape at that time the hard
work paid off despite what Family Guy
would lead you to believe no matter how
muscular I get I will never be muscular
Walton Goggins ordeal before the shield
took TV by storm Walton Goggins was
known mainly for bid parts in 90s
programs like in the heat of the night
I've always got it man
taking on the role of Shane Vendrell put
the future star in the spotlight but
execs hated his performance early on in
fact he was almost fired from the show
he told Nashville Scene the brass at FX
saw the pilot and they thought is he
irritating I can't read him
if Goggins had never played Shane and
the shield he may have never gotten to
play memorable characters like justified
spoi Crowder or the hateful aids Chris
Mannix would anyone want to live in that
reality game over back in 2006 Fox
teamed up with Sony to release 24 the
game for the PlayStation 2 Kiefer
Sutherland fans got to step into Jack
Bauer's shoes battling bad guys against
the ticking clock a year later the
shield tried the same formula a game
based on the show was released for the
PlayStation 2 in PC much like the 24
game the shield was a third-person
shooter the game involved a gang war
between two rival crews and it wasn't
well-received at all in its two-star
review IGN said you'd be better off
avoiding this one as it makes great
strides to damage the otherwise high
quality of the franchise in other words
this experiments failed
go on arrest me a murderous reality
throughout the run of the show actor
Michael chase played the role of officer
Julian Lowe a strict Christian who hid
his homosexuality from his wife and crew
in 2014 the actors career came to a
violent halt Jayce was arrested for
fatally shooting his wife April in front
of their two sons prosecutors claimed
their horrific crime was motivated by
jealousy the mirror shared part of the
trials transcript claiming Jace admitted
he was angry at the time and said all I
intended to do was shoot her in the leg
and then I shot her in the leg and that
was it
Jace was convicted of second-degree
murder and sentenced to 40 years to life
in prison a shield reunion TV reboots
like the recently revived Will & Grace
are all the rage right now so it's
understandable that fans of the shield
wonder if the show might return one day
sounds like series creator Sean Ryan is
kicking the idea around to during a
panel discussion at the 2016 SAT X
television festival he said I don't know
where Vic Mackey is until someone puts
me in a writers room so could Vic Mackey
return one day ryan tells Entertainment
Weekly I've never definitively decided
what Vic Mackey is doing now as a fan of
the shield I'm interested
seeing that so are we thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]